[Music]
it's a very
friendly version of carpool karaoke
after hosting the friends reunion on hbo
max last month
james corden released an 11 minute clip
with the cast of the hit 90s sitcom
on wednesday's the late late show it was
glorious the late night tv host picked
up
lisa kudrow courtney cox jennifer
aniston matt leblanc
david schwimmer and matthew perry in a
golf cart on the warner brothers studio
lot
after they've been filming the reunion
for a day and a half
and that's when they blessed our ears
with this
i was wondering if it was okay with you
if we could listen to some music would
that be okay
are you ready yeah okay here we go
yep the cast hit us with the show's
classic theme song
claps and all
they didn't miss a
for beat but the sweet throwback moment
was interrupted after the group parked
outside the set of central park coffee
shop
or at least they thought they did could
you imagine
that was it dead
honestly just kid nearly killed the cast
of friends of course this isn't the only
recent musical performance from the cast
of friends
back in february court gave us her
rendition of the sitcom's famous theme
song
on the piano
[Music]
and back in may during the highly
anticipated reunion special
lisa kudrow performed her character
phoebe's iconic song smelly cat
this time with a little help from lady
[Music]
[Applause]
gaga
e.t recently caught up with lisa and she
dished on having
so much star power at the big reunion
what was it like having them all kind of
in the orbit
it was it was really thrilling because
they like friends so much so
yeah it was really it was great it was
fun and while the reunion included a
who's who of hollywood with stars like
mother monster david beckham cindy
crawford and
justin bieber making appearances lisa
told e.t
she was mostly just excited to see her
old friends
shooting that shooting any of it being
in the same room
with these people and getting to hug
them that was the best
and the feeling was mutual e.t recently
sat down with the whole cast and
they opened up about how emotional it
was to be together on the same set
17 years after the show wrapped how
amazing was it actually to be back i
know you guys are friends anyway to be
back
in this set on the set with you all all
together kind of in this
zone again it was the most emote i i
i had slept so well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all
just feeling good the first question
like how do you feel i was like
and then started crying over the 10
years obviously we really
grew close as a family and part of the
reason was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to or or was
going through except the other five
actors so
um we really we really got close because
of
that experience too all i can say is
that there was something
that was laid down at the very very
beginning that kind of went into our
neural pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this